there is a great push now for some type
of National Health Service national
health care the United States is the
only Western capitalist country outside
of South Africa if you consider that a
advanced Western capitalist country
which doesn't have some type of
comprehensive health care system are the
Libertarians for this are they against
it
well we're for we're for a comprehensive
health care system that we want
everybody to have major medical coverage
and the best insurance and the best
medical care
that's why edica care has to be
delivered by the free market if we don't
care about medical care and quality if
we you like lines and if you like the
medical care the Indians get and if
you're happy with the Veterans Hospital
if you're happy with how England runs
things in the Soviet Union and I guess
we need another move in the direction of
socialized medicine government now even
though we don't have a a major national
program government now delivers 60% of
the health care in this country the more
we spend the higher the costs the lower
the quality less people to get to care I
mean it's a lousy delivery system poor
people who can buy their TVs and cars
and video cassette recorders have no
health care they buy the VCRs and their
televisions and the cars in the
marketplace they get their healthcare
through government in program with all
their spending there are still 38
million people who have no insurance
whatsoever just devising it and they get
another government program which won't
work but just further push up costs and
put controls and more doctors dropping
out and I think it is a total disaster
if it's a national health program run by
the government it's tragic it won't work
it's going to ruin the care in the
country if we care about people we will
have a national health care program but
it will be delivered by the free market
but the free market is what we have now
we have bad health care we have a
greater percentage of GNP being spent on
health care than those places within
those countries where they have the
government yeah I don't agree I don't
think that we have free market medicine
as I said that 60% is paid by government
we have coerced
some rules that force governments into
these HMO organizations government you
know the large companies had to offer
these things so they've been growing and
now going bankrupt and when you pump a
lot of money in if government's paying
the bills through Medicare or Medicaid
this doesn't spread the money a lot of
wealthy people get to benefits the poor
people don't seem to get through the you
know the maze of papers but a lot of
millionaires receive Medicare benefits
so they get their Hospital payments but
when they go in and pay and have a
little insurance what happens the
hospitals and doctors in the labs tend
to you know jack up the prices so and
then the government has to come in and
say what we're going to put on controls
because the prices are too high and then
we're gonna ration care so one problem
leads leads to the next but the problems
you see today I result of 50 years of
ever-increasing government intervention
in medicine the the government doesn't
pays for 60% of our automobiles you know
but they pay for 60% of our medical care
the the automobile prices are high but
they're not as high proportionately
speaking cost of automobiles going up at
the rate of about four or five percent a
year because the medical care is going
up about 15 or 20 percent governments in
in education they're in college
education are always subsidizing college
education always the guy that doesn't
get to go to college has to this subsidy
out of the guy that gets to go the cost
of education is going up about 15 to 20
percent so as soon as you get government
involved quality does not go up but the
cost goes up and there's not any fair
distribution where do you stand on the
the right-to-lifers and those folks like
you they anti-abortion people like the
libertarians it's mixed they like me
because I'm a right to life liberty
Rhian I believe killing a fetus is an
act of aggression I've been forced to be
in a room unfortunately when I saw a
three-pound and fetus the infant taken
out breathing and cried and thrown in a
bucket I mean I took Mike I take my
plate seriously I mean that to me look
like an act of aggression besides if I
get the wrong medication as a physician
to a mother and I damage the fetus the
fetus when it's born can sue me
obviously it was legal alive inhuman or
couldn't be able to wouldn't be able to
sue me I know the fetus determines its
inheritance rights at the time of
conception so I mean I I'm in
disagreement with our platform but there
were enough libertarians who agree with
my position that I went on the first
ballot at our convention the truth is
it's a difficult issue and nobody likes
to think about it because the way the
law states now under Roe vs. Wade the
fetus one second before birth and the
weight of nine pounds still has no legal
rights and nobody enjoys defending that
position very difficult because I as a
libertarian I don't like to interfere
with the privacy of a woman either but
how are we going to deal with this I
think we have to have respect for human
life or we can't have respect for
individual liberty and the right to
smoke a cigarette so you think the
government the government has the right
to force a woman to carry a fetus
full-term then I think the government
has the right to protect life is sort of
like saying if the baby's born in the IQ
is 65 and they wanted a hundred does the
government have the right to force that
person not to kill their baby yes I do
think so I think the government has a
right to protect life but the government
doesn't have the right to force anything
so it's it is difficult obviously but I
think the bottom line is is killing a
fetus and act of aggression and the only
way the libertarians are others who
disagree with me on that would they
would have to say that no it's obviously
an act of aggression there's no debate
there it's that the fetus is not a
person and the pea fetuses are not alive
and it's not human and I as a physician
had a lot of trouble with that I mean I
know it's alive I know it's human I know
it's legal so this is very unique you
know I don't advocate any federal laws I
don't mean you know we libertarians nor
this system that we have advocated
federal laws to deal with the theft or
murder or anything you know it's all
handled by the state so I think that the
states would handle it differently I
think courts would handle different
I think juries would handle it
differently but I think under my ideal
situation we wouldn't have people having
abortion on demand and using it as birth
control and having a callous attitude
about life and instead of having less
illegitimate pregnancies or births
illegitimate or unwanted pregnancies now
it actually it was intended to help
difficult situations but what has done
is that the teenager sometimes can have
three abortions in the year which is sad
and it's a tragedy and I've seen
tragedies I've witnessed them and I have
a great empathy for them but I also have
great respect for the principles of
freedom and I don't want to infringe or
compromise my concept of what it Liberty
is